james aquí la jefe de prensa de la casa
blanca dijo anoche en un comunicado que
eeuu se opone a cualquier intento de
alterar los resultados de las elecciones
pasadas y de alterar la transición
democrática en mianmar aquí también les
dijo que el presidente yo walden está
muy enterado de la situación y que eeuu
tomará acciones contra los responsables
si éstos no revisan los pasos que
tomaron y dejan en libertad hoy a los
líderes que tienen precios por su parte
el secretario de estado ante el inem
dijo que washington está del lado del
pueblo que eligió de forma democrática a
estos líderes que hoy están presos por
los militares